es una de las vías marítimas más
concurridas del mundo todos los días en
las costas de cal emigrantes se
aventuran clandestinamente por el canal
de la mancha en busca de una vida mejor
el viaje a menudo se hace a bordo de
pequeños y hacinados botes inflables
durante este año 31 mil 500 migrantes se
embarcaron en esta peligrosa travesía
una cifra más de dos veces mayor a la
del año previo siete mil 800 migrantes
debieron ser rescatados la crisis se ha
acrecentado por la pandemia que ha
reducido el tráfico de camiones una ley
efe creo que muchas de las personas que
originalmente intentaron llegar entre
camiones como polizones en contenedores
o en barcos ahora directamente optan por
tomar botes lo que se ha convertido en
la principal ruta que utilizan los
migrantes irregulares para llegar a
reino unidos
en lo que va de año 41 personas se
ahogaron intentando llegar a gran
bretaña esto es más de 4 veces la cifra
del 2020 las autoridades están luchando
por reducir los intentos de cruce allí
inmigrantes y policías juegan al gato y
al ratón en las dunas de kale pero una
vez en el mar las autoridades francesas
no tienen poder para frenarlos
no los arrestamos es demasiado peligroso
los acompañamos y protegemos todo el
camino hasta el reino unido si esto ha
llegado a suceder a veces tenemos que
recorrer todo el camino hasta reino
unido el pasado julio el reino unido-
pagó 62,7 millones de euros para frenar
los cruces a través de patrullas y de
vigilancia las autoridades británicas
instan a su vecino a ser más firme el
ministro de interior francés anunció
esta semana que las fuerzas de seguridad
tendrán más recursos para luchar contra
la migración irregular a lo largo de la
costa del canal